I'm Justin Feld and I'm a scout master with Troop 89 in Downers Grove, Illinois.
This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Thanks for everything you do, Clark.
And now see you, scout master.
On a recent camping trip we had this fantastic campsite at the base of a big
cliff and I overheard a couple of my scouts kind of arguing with each other
and what what had happened was is one had bet the other that he
couldn't climb that cliff and cook their dinner up on top of the
cliff.
And I don't like to step in usually, but I had to put a stop to
it because the stakes were just too high.
Hello,
If you've got a better joke than that, and everybody should
right, send it in.
Hey, this is podcast number 221..
Hey, welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mail bag.
We heard from Chris this past week, who wrote to say I just
wanted to thank you for the wonderful emails and blog posts
and things.
My son just crossed into a scout troop from Weeblows.
I agreed to be an assistant scout master.
I was a den leader and I'm now a cub master for the pack.
I'm finding your information to be thought-provoking and a
fabulous resources.
I assume my new roles with both the troop and the pack,
So thank you.
Well, thank you, Chris, for being in touch.
I am so happy to find that people find this useful
And I really appreciate your support
Heard from Dave Self via Facebook.
I just had a coworker ask me some questions about possibly
starting up a new troop, and I primarily pointed him to
scout master CG's blog and podcast to help him get
off on the right foot.
Well, thanks, Dave.
Hopefully we can help him do that.
Tell him to get in touch with us.
Love to hear from him
Over on the blog. this week,
One of the things we posted was an infographic about three
things scout parents can do to help out with gear.
It's kind of specific, isn't it?
But you know I had three pieces of advice.
One was: make sure to put your scout's name and troop
number on everything,
And if he has a common first name, you know, make
sure to put the last name on there too, or at least
the last initial, because if they're attending an
event with dozens or hundreds of other scouts and
they misplace something, it's got a much better chance
of finding its way back to them
If it is marked. the second piece of advice was:
don't pack for your scout- and I don't really need
to elaborate on that,
Do I?
But just from a practical standpoint, if you pack
everything for your scout, the scout is not really
going to understand what he has with him or
even know how to find it.
And the third piece of advice was: help scouts
keep track of their gear.
I can't tell you how many times a scout has told
me that they're without some key piece of gear
because they couldn't find it at home
After each camping trip. make sure that they're
putting it someplace, like in one of those big plastic
containers or something like that, so they'll be
able to find it next time.
This, these three things, will help your scouts
and they will help save a scout master's
sanity from time to time. to Kathy responded:
I know your advice is spot on.
What I didn't realize was how challenging it would
be to be a parent with who is a little bit of a
control freak.
Kathy went on to say: the first step is admitting
you have a problem. right,
I'm learning and I'm pretty sure my son is too.
Yeah, Kathy, we all run into this and but really
you know. let them pack when they're going out
on a camping trip.
They'll forget a few things.
I still forget things after 40 years of camping,
But the way that you learn is: you know
sometimes you don't have what exactly what you need.
If you want to be involved in the whole packing procedure,
just help them, you know, have a list and check
things off.
It's pretty simple.
Just don't do it for them because, like I said,
they won't know what they have or where it is. in
last week's podcast,
One of the answers to an email question involved
talking about logistical success versus mission
success.
I heard from John Dyer who said the excellent nugget
in last week's podcast was comparing logistical
success to mission success.
Wow,
And my ears perk up at that.
This is one that also applies to so much more
than scouting.
Where did you first hear these two terms together?
Well, John, I was writing a reply to that email
and it just kind of came up.
I'm sure that the two ideas have been put together
in other places somewhere.
I can't really remember reading it before.
It's probably not an original idea,
If you. if you're not sure what I'm talking
about here, folks, and you haven't listened to the
last podcast, go back and listen to the email
section and where we make that comparison,
We also heard from- obviously a screen name,
the hypoxic marmot.
But the hypoxic marmot wrote in to say recently
I stumbled into the podcast and I'm enjoying it.
Well, I apologize if I left podcasts kind of laid
around so that you stumbled over them.
but they went on to say I played the recent segment
of Brick Mason to my son and he looked at me and asked:
is this where you're getting all of your stupid jokes?
Well, you know, we, we- we- try to serve on many
levels and provide scouters with stupid jokes
to amaze their scouts with.
Anyway, the marmot went on to say on the topic
of high adventure, as a relatively new scouter
I was puzzled at the strong pull in our troop to
do high adventure camps that had higher costs
associated with them.
I cannot figure out why we would go backpacking
in New Mexico, when we live in one of the most
wonderful places in the world, to go backpacking
the state of Colorado.
Our scouts are in the midst of planning
and preparation of a backpacking trip on the Colorado
Trail at probably one tenth the cost of what
it would take to go to film on, and we hope
it will give them an appreciation of the wonder
in their own backyard.
Keep up the good fight and thank you.
Well, thank you for getting in touch.
Yeah, I agree,
A lot of the big trips to the nationally sponsored
high adventure bases. they can be kind of pricey
and they they're out of my reach most times
and I think they're out of the reach of a lot
of my families. you know, unless we do some
pretty intensive fundraising or we really go on
a two year cycle where people are paying
over time.
And that's why I'm a big advocate of simple,
local kind of homespun high adventure.
I'm certainly not an enemy of the bigger,
more ambitious trips, but I think the point
is is there are lots of high adventure opportunities
out there and every troop should have some
kind of high adventure program, if you ask me.
Last week we also were talking about Scout
Service projects and Jim Woods replied:
I have to revisit my idea of having a blanket
approval for camp out service projects
and Eagle Service projects.
Well, Jim, I think that might be a good thing
to revisit.
You know, just as a matter of course I
approve most of the service projects
the Scouts bring to my attention.
My chief objection just to having a blanket
approval is that Scouts don't end up talking
to us and approving those service projects
for second class and star and life.
Well, you know that's. that's a really great
opportunity to have something to talk to
a Scout about,
And when we have that, I like to take that
opportunity.
I'm glad that we got you thinking about
that at least.
So if you're finding the resources we offer
at ScoutmasterCGcom- the blog posts and
the podcast and all the other things
that we've created are helping you-
You can return the favor by becoming
a backer.
Funds that we receive from backers make
it possible to publish all of the resources
that we create and keep them freely
available to Scouters all over the world,
And since last week, Jeff Zazeta signed
up to be a backer.
Thank you so much, Jeff.
Thanks for helping us out here.
I really do appreciate it.
It's very easy to become a backer:
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom,
Follow the support link right there
at the top of the page and you'll
get the whole story on that.
Well, in this podcast in Scout
Master's ship, in seven minutes or
less, we're going to talk a little
bit about real responsibility
And then we've got a couple of email
questions to answer and that's going
to take up the rest of the entire
podcast.
So let's get started, shall we
Scout Master's ship in seven
minutes or less?
Scouting gives young people the
opportunity to develop into contributing,
capable and empathetic adults.
Scouting is much more than just
leadership, development and leadership.
You know, we all agree it's an important
quality, but it's not all there is. real
leadership actually is based on
a strong character.
So our principal name is developing
character, not necessarily developing
leadership.
We're not really aimed at that.
Principally, what we do is we give
people the opportunity to develop
strong character, and the most
important things a Scout learns are
those intangible things that they
get out of their experiences in scouting.
I've seen touching demonstrations of
tolerance and friendship and heroic
endurance of difficult circumstances
as we watch this development of
inner character, of inner strength
in our Scouts. and without that
inner strength and that character,
there's no basis for developing
leadership, is there?
So, just to differentiate a little
bit between the two: develop character
and you'll develop leadership.
Develop just leadership.
You can do that without really touching
on those intangible character
elements sometimes.
So how do we really get at this?
How do we really get at this development
of character?
Well, one of the key elements is
something that is almost wholly unique
to scouting, and I call it real
responsibility, and we enable Scouts
to have real responsibility for
themselves and for their fellow Scouts.
Now, what is real responsibility?
Well, I would argue that real
responsibility is the kind of
responsibility that functions without
a safety net in a lot of ways,
You know, naturally, we're going to make
sure that our Scouts are physically
and emotionally and mentally safe-
All right, we're going to make
sure that that happens, but we're
not going to prevent every single failure.
Scouting does its best to
optimize the ability to succeed,
but to have real responsibility,
that means there's the latitude for failure.
There's little sense of accomplishment
when something is achieved in an
environment that has eliminated
all possibility of failing.
Failures are pretty charged word,
isn't it?
We've been conditioned to think
that failure is altogether negative,
but mistakes teach us some of life's
most valuable lessons.
You and I, we did not end up
where we are because we never failed.
We ended up where we are because
we failed and learned from those failures.
As a wrestling coach, I welcomed
the hard matches and even welcomed
losing them, because those-
quote- failures, unquote- provided
us with more opportunity for
learning and sharpening our skills
than just going into a match
and running over the other team.
No championship team gets to
their goal without significant development
and much of that development is based
on how they incorporate the lessons
that their failures and losses teach.
Handled properly, failure is
a very positive influence and it
provides really sharp insight into
what you're doing and intense motivation.
So when a scout fails,
it's up to us adults to take
that failure and to turn it into a teachable
moment and ultimately, a positive experience.
And it's not really that hard to do, is it?
Scouting is not designed for efficiency.
There are supposed to be lots of bumps
and setbacks along the way.
They are supposed to be challenges,
and those challenges and bumps
and setbacks are evidence that
scouts have real responsibility.
We're on hand to coach and to train and encourage,
but never to totally eliminate
the possibility of failing or
to bail scouts out of tough spots.
We want to work with them
to get through these things.
So the frustrations of an
inefficient youth led program-
They are a welcome thing to us.
We don't want to eliminate
those things,
We want to welcome them.
These experiences are the ones
that build character
And when we take them and we accept them
as a positive influence,
not only in our scouts lives,
but in our lives as well.
we're going to come out on top
and we're going to have
what I like to call real responsibility
that leads to the development of
good, strong character
and, as a result,
the development of leadership.
I'm
down the river,
It's a beautiful day.
The birds and with such bliss
paddle in my hand and the trees above
Don't get any better than this.
In my blue canoes,
in my blue canoes,
I'm canoeing, canoeing, canoe too.
Write me a letter, send it by name,
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Hey, if you are spending any time
looking at the blog lately,
every once in a while,
while I'm working on a blog,
I'll turn on the chat feature
and I'll get to talk to readers
and listeners one-on-one.
And if you haven't seen this yet,
go to the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and there's this aggravating little bouncing balloon
at the bottom right hand part of the page.
If you click on that,
it'll take you to the chat feature.
If I'm not there,
there's a contact form
that you can fill out,
And I received one of the letters
that I received
that you can fill out,
And I received one question
over a contact form last week
that said,
how can I run a Cub Scout pack
if no one is willing to lead or help?
And well you know,
obviously you can't, right?
Nobody can really run anything
if there's no one willing to lead or help.
I guess you could for a little while,
but if no one's willing to help,
you're gonna get pretty tired pretty fast
and things are not going to go well.
The good news here
is that people are usually
very willing to help
once they understand that they're needed.
So here's what I suggest you do:
You call a meeting of all the parents
that are involved with the Cub Scout pack
and you make it clear that at least
one parent per family
is asked to be at this meeting
and promise that it's only gonna last
for 15 minutes-
Really only 15 minutes.
So, before the meeting, get some index cards
and list one task that needs to be completed
or one position that needs to be filled
on each index card.
Open the meeting by welcoming everybody
and tell them that you have a number of opportunities
for helping make the Cub program
possible for their sons,
and then read each card you've prepared
and tack them to a bulletin board
or tape them on the wall right there behind you.
Conclude by saying
that everyone will need to pitch in
and that each of the parent's presence
needs to choose what they would like to do
out of the cards
that are tacked there on the wall
and tell them: you know, the most attractive opportunities
are probably gonna go first.
so everybody should hop right up
and grab the job
or the task that they like the most:
One, two, three
ready set go,
And you know they'll sit there for a moment
until they understand that
oh, this is serious.
I actually have to do this now,
and the first parent will get up
and take a card and then everybody will do it,
and there's kind of a fun spirit to it.
It's kind of a game, isn't it?
And then ask everyone who's
taken a card to write their name
and contact information on the card
and hand it back to you before they leave.
Tell them you'll be contacting them soon
about what happens next,
thank them for their time
and say that you're looking forward to working together.
Now, this might sound a little improbable,
but I gotta tell you this actually works
When you get these parents together.
if your attitude is being forceful
and demanding, you're not going to get very good results
If you just kind of warm them up
and you make them feel wanted and important,
and if you're cheerful and optimistic
about this whole thing,
you're going to be surprised about how well it goes.
Give it a shot and get back in touch
and let me know how it works,
And I have this email
and I'm going to withhold
the contact information involved with it.
I've been following your blog
for months with passion
and I thank you. I'm learning a lot.
When my son became a scout,
I signed up as a counselor
for various merit badges
and I volunteered for all other activities
when adults are needed to accompany the scouts
on camping trips and things like that.
I've also completed all the online
scouter training courses
and I've started to educate myself
about the scouting program,
and I found your blog and your podcast as a result.
Not too long after I became involved
in the scouting program,
I started to learn
about replacing our retiring scoutmaster.
At first, I declined
because I was pretty sure that others
who had been involved with the troop logger
would be more qualified,
but I was approached again
by the current scoutmaster,
who encouraged me to take on the task,
since at that point
no one else was willing to do it.
I accepted,
but I was reluctant to do so
and I didn't intend to devote myself
to doing the best job I can possibly do
and to educating myself
about exactly how to do that.
Now, at a recent meeting,
I intervened after I
saw that the scouts weren't organized
for the meeting. They had no agenda
and they had done no planning, despite my offer of assistance.
I spent some time coaching them
about this. My mistake
was probably I didn't follow your rules
by asking only questions
which I should probably learn to do.
Well, yeah, you'll get it.
At the end of the meeting,
a committee member and a parent pulled me aside
and after 30 minutes of kind of arguing
back and forth about how I was doing the job,
I had to end our discussion.
I was upset by their criticism of my work.
I mean, it's only been a week or two
and I still have a lot to figure out,
so I'm looking for a little advice.
Well, I gotta tell you
that is a familiar story.
Now, nobody else wanted to take on
the challenge of being the scoutmaster
and they finally managed to get you to do it,
but apparently
they're all experts in exactly
how you should be doing the job right.
I mean, you have to laugh.
There's a sense of humor in this
and I understand that
this is getting you down.
but all these people were asked probably-
and I really don't want to do it,
but I'm perfectly willing
to tell the new scoutmaster how to do things.
Well, I want to address
your concerns
and I want to think about
the concerns of the troop committee
and encourage everybody
just to kind of calm down a little,
because things are going to be fine
Now. from the new
scoutmasters standpoint,
it's upsetting when things like this happen-
and they will happen
from time to time.
It sounds to me like you're
committed, you're devoted,
you're doing fine.
Naturally, you're going to make some mistakes,
but we all learn this as we go along.
That's what all of us have done.
so don't be impatient
with yourself.
Just keep on going and that devotion,
that passion for the work
is going to win out.
These kinds of transitions in any scout troop
are rarely easy.
They're stressful for everyone
and they require an extra measure of patience
all around.
Now, in the email I received,
you went into much more detail
about the scout master
committee member argument that you referenced,
but I would say a good way
of summarizing it was basically
over what you had said
and whether you were coaching
or directing.
What's interesting is that the committee member
decided that they would
be able to direct you
rather than coach you.
so they weren't really applying
what they were arguing about, were they?
If I had the ear of that committee member,
the minimum of a couple of things.
One is that they should be working in concert
with the rest of the committee
and that the chair of the committee
and the scout master are the ones
who ought to be discussing these things,
rather than a committee member
just kind of taking ad hoc initiative
to do this.
And it should be clearly understood
that anybody who is stepped up
into the scout master position-
especially someone who filled the position
because no one else was willing to do it-
to report an encouragement as possible.
I mean, how would any of us feel
if, in their brand new position
that we kind of got a little pressured into,
if someone started criticizing
our work the first week we took on the job?
No doubt
the committee member in question
is trying to be helpful, but let's get real here.
That kind of thing
is not really helping.
The key concept
I think that bears on the situation
is that, when it comes to the committee
and all of the parents of the scouts.
they need to accept
that the scout master is going to
lead adults. He's the head coach
and all the other adults kind of need to
follow in line and follow the head coach.
This is not to say
that the scout master is going to order
everybody around or not be open
to suggestions,
but that role of leadership
is something that needs to be respected.
The scout master has the right to accept
or reject advice, to make decisions,
to set the way forward. If the committee
and the parents have basic
disagreements with this
and they aren't willing to accept this arrangement,
they should find another scout master
And I would suggest
that the new scout master sent me this email:
you'd go and discuss this with the committee
and make sure that everybody is agreed
on a way forward and you know things
will smooth out. You're always going to have
some challenges and difficulties
with your fellow adults
and with the parents of the scouts.
you're going to learn to work with those.
You need to make sure the committee understands
you have a clear expectation
that they're going to back you up,
that they're going to intervene when parents
or other adults become a problem
and leave you to focus on your work
with the scouts. You have to be
very direct and definite about this.
It's not something that we can just
kind of say is understood
without discussing it. You have to demand
this kind of support.
Make it clear that you have no interest
in being a scout master
unless you do have that kind of support.
Now I read your email
and I know that you're a good-hearted,
sensitive person,
that you're interested in getting along with people,
and so going to
have this kind of direct discussion
and being as demanding and definitive
as I've encouraged you to be
is going to make you a little uncomfortable.
I want you to do it anyways.
If I could talk to the committee on your behalf,
I would say:
obviously you saw some kind of promise
in the individual that you appointed to be the scout master,
otherwise you wouldn't have asked them
to serve. Now I want to encourage
you to have some respect for the challenge
of stepping into the role
and cut up some slack, please.
The committee chair ought to be working
hand in hand with the scout master
and everyone else on the committee,
and parents should either reserve
their comments or funnel them through the committee chair.
Let's keep it simple
and let's respect
the leadership structure of a Boy Scout troop.
And finally, I would
add, if I was able to talk to the committee-
your loyalty to the new scout master
extends to your attitude
with the scouts,
especially the scout that lives
in your home. Any indication
that you're not 100% behind the scout master
is going to undermine their ability
to do their job effectively.
so watch what you say
and watch what kind of attitude you represent
to the scouts in general
and the scout who happens to be your child.
Hey, if you have a question
or a conundrum or a difficulty
I can help you with.
you can get in touch and you'll find out how to do that
in just a moment.
Thank you for listening to this
221st edition
of the Scout Master Podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch. Go to the blog
scoutmastercgcom and make sure you subscribe
to receive updates to the blog
by email. You can get individual updates.
you can get a digest over the week.
you can get the scout master CG
app on google play
or at the iTunes app store. It's the best
way to keep all of these resources that we
create right there at your fingertips
on your mobile device. You can experience
the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
Join the 5300 folks
who like scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
Tweet along with the
1020 tweeters on Twitter.
pin the poultry goodness pictures,
profiled publicly with 1500
other prolific pinners
on Pinterest and watch
us at scoutmastercg on youtube.
join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive scoutmastercg
circle on google
plus. but listen,
you know, if you can't face facebook,
if twitter makes you better, if you have no interest
in Pinterest, if you
don't put the you in you
tube, if you're a minus when it comes
to google plus, don't worry, monkey,
you can zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email.
I'm at Clark at
scoutmastercgcom.
it's C-L-A-R-K-E
at
scoutmastercgcom.
to those of you who are not previously aware,
the scoutmaster podcast is not an official
publication of any scouting
organization, nor is it endorsed
or sponsored by any
scouting organization. it's just me.
I'm pretty sure these scouting organizations
have much better things to do. I've got
a microphone and a laptop and a way to
get on the internet and I like to lend
hand to scouts and have a little bit of fun along
the way. so you know, take it with a grain
of salt, make sure to check out your
local resources and
let me know if I've gotten something
wrong, will you please? hey, speaking of fun,
here's our founder, sir Robert.
good luck to you and good camping.
oh, I thank you, sir,
until next time everyone.